earlier this week MSNBC did something
interesting they did a town hall called
the Trump country in Kenosha Wisconsin
Chris Hayes was the host of it and they
had senator and former presidential
candidate Bernie Sanders attend now
before I even tell you the story if
you're watching with me this expression
on Bernie Sanders face that you see in
the picture that we're displaying this
expression tells you everything you need
to know about how this thing went and
I'm going to start with Vermont senator
Bernie Sanders calmly walking a Trump
voter through how Republicans are
planning to gut the social safety net
this Trump voter insisted that no one's
listening to small-town voters like her
and actually started saying we're paying
into all of these things uh and and I'm
concerned that we're paying in and
paying in and we're not getting out what
we should be getting out this applies to
taxes and Social Welfare etcetera which
is actually sort of sort of a
progressive idea in many ways let's
start with this uh uh and you will see
how she doesn't even realize as Bernie
Sanders astutely explains to her if
these are your views you voted for the
guy who doesn't agree with what you are
saying Bernie Sanders explains it very
very clearly to her and she agrees with
Bernie but you can tell she doesn't
really get that she voted against her
own best interest by voting for Trump
take a look at this okay but down here's
good good points let's see if we do I'll
throw it on this I'm assuming that you
believe correct me if I'm wrong that we
should not cut Social Security on
Medicare or Medicaid is that correct
what up yeah okay I believe it shouldn't
be cut okay do you know who is now
working very hard to try to do that
Republicans in Congress have a plan
under the guise of saving Medicare and
saving Social Security making
devastating cuts that's publicans are
now trying to do the other point that
you made which is a very I think you bet
it was you both of you have made it
actually is who's gonna pay for this
stuff and that is a very fair point
what all of us should know is that over
the last 25 years there has been a
massive transfer of wealth in this
country from you to the top 1/10 of 1%
in other words the middle class has
shrunk and trillions of dollars have
gone to the top one-tenth of one percent
do you think it's inappropriate to ask
those people to stop paying their fair
share of taxes so we can adequately fund
Medicaid in making public colleges and
universities tuition-free is that an
unfair thing pass I don't think it's an
unfair yeah that's right so it's time
they put back ok all right well I'm
sorry Bernie Sanders visibly perplexed
that's just the best isn't it she still
has no idea that she voted for the wrong
person based on what you want to see
happen
yeah it upsets me in a way because this
guy would have beaten Trump I'm pretty
sure of that they the people wanted a
populist they didn't want some hack like
Hillary Clinton here's one other great
moment where they are all saying that we
can ignore all the crazy stuff Trump
said during the campaign because it
wasn't true and Bernie Sanders points
out you're defending Trump by saying we
should have all just understood he was
lying during the campaign it's an
amazing moment take a look there's no
question to my mind I find it
interesting that what three out of four
of you are saying is yeah he talked
about that stuff but it'll never happen
we don't believe that it will ever
happen uh why do you vote for somebody
who in a sense than his lines
[Applause]
concerning a dialogue with the American
people and he used the media to get his
point across it hinges but he wasn't
lying he started the dialogue he voiced
his opinion and he he got feedback and
he addressed it as he went along he
knows as well as anybody in this room
you can't go after a group of people
because of religious beliefs it's never
and I knew that right off the bat well
but he was still upright he talked to
the public what's an interesting point I
mean what you're saying is that you
think and I think the what he was
talking about was unconstitutional
you got a candidate for president of the
United States talking about grossly
unconstitutional things and wins an
election well look what our Congress
does it says every day watching this did
make me realize Pat that these people
cannot be taught you can't make
individuals that are this committed to
nonsense
understand there is no argument to be
made we just need to outnumber them
through voter turnout the if we want to
figure out how to win elections
progresses having conversations with
folks like this and trying to change
their minds it's not going to be nearly
as effective as just go vote and
Bernie's logic on these things always
gets portrayed as pie in the sky it's
very straightforward in took this woman
only a minute or so to be persuaded it
took her only a minute to be persuaded
that she agreed with Bernie but I think
what's missing is the connection that oh
maybe she should have voted for someone
else
because the person she voted for wants
the opposite of what she just said makes
sense that's the missing piece though
and you should vote for someone who
actually believes in what they say
yeah well that so I mean you Wow Wow Pat
that sounds like a really crazy thing